this money is to get my wizna s-- woman
on business up and running
oh you mean phone wigs I'm using mine
right now I mean a line in real life
every once in a while sure like wear her
a week to a party how that way Excel up
here this is kind of what you get theory
in prior seasons Alana's had like wigs
sewn into the back of her helmet I do
you want tell him I kept that be stunt
double wig to just wear and be her say
weird wigs
Lana's phone wigs they are key prop from
this season they were designed and
created by Marcel dejeuner our key hair
guy phone wigs have never been made
before so it was a lot of engineering to
figure it out I honestly I wouldn't
normally do this that I believe I
pitched it and then it was like another
wigs invention it's the same as the
helmet yeah but it's a theme but it's so
funny and then we like student went nuts
with like who she would make there's one
for Abbi Ilana it's Lincoln High May
this one was made out of a wig that
Ilana wore in season four
that's the Ross the Rachel the Gunther
from friends that's Michelle Obama and
Bernadette Peters a lot of times I'll
see them on camera and I'm like yeah you
know so usually I ask props to bring
them by me and to get a little quaff to
do a little pick a lot of ones anyway
[Music]